brought to you by msi computers msi  number one in gaming find out more at us  msi com hey guys Jess McDonald here with  a news update for our cosmic explorers  here at e3 2015 the highly anticipated  and wildly ambitious space exploration  game no man's sky will launch on PC the  same day as the ps4 version Shaun Murray  co-founder of hello games went on to say  that they plan to announce a release  date for no man's sky during e3 but  plans shifted for unspecified reasons  Murray promised that a release date will  be revealed soon Shaun Murray also took  the stage during the Sony conference to  show us a brief demo for no man's sky  showed us just how massive the universe  is for this summer and much much more  from e3 2015 be sure to stay tuned to  gamespot